nu alors il ya ici genou droit il ya
monsieur brassens on est tous deux que
nous aimons tous bons et quel courage
doute sa vie d'être finie la même
chanson à boujan à venir chanter l'amour
oui mais ça c'est autre chose là c'est
un gendarme j'oublie quand même je suis
en face des militaires je suis anti
militariste et que les approuve
totalement qu'on le soit m'enfin chacun
peut combler les gens droite mais sous
le militaire yeux non mais si cet homme
comme ce flic là m'a rendu service à un
moment de ma vie
j'oublie j'oublie que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord j'ai vraiment dû service n'ont
cessé les premiers que je voudrais quand
même